it's Juneteenth a great time to
celebrate American history the goalposts
for anti racism keep moving further and
further down the field and Joe Biden
gets a pass on like everything I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the bench Bureau show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressive VPN your data is your
business protected at Express at VPN
calm slash Ben we're gonna get to all
the news in just a moment today of
course is Juneteenth which is the date
that commemorates the last state to be
read the Emancipation Proclamation at
the end of the Civil War was Texas and
the Emancipation Proclamation was read
to a group of now freed slaves in Texas
on this date in 1865 we'll talk about
that and then we will talk about the
legacy of American history and exactly
the after-effects of all of this and why
we are now having debates over whether
America is truly free we'll get to all
of that in just a moment first despite
everything that's going on there are a
lot of good things that we can
appreciate like what zip recruiter is
doing right now they're continuing to do
what they have always done helping
people find jobs and helping companies
hire for their teams we may be in a
v-shaped recovery we can always hope I
mean it seems like the economy wants to
bounce back people want to get back to
work and if you're a job seeker zip
recruiter is focused on helping you find
work faster they send you
up-to-the-minute relevant jobs through
their app so you can be one of the first
to apply if you're a company that needs
to add to their team quickly zip
recruiter is dedicated to making hiring
easier they actively invite top
candidates to apply to your job so you
find the best possible people right away
in fact zip recruiter is committed to
connecting people and employers to
address the most immediate needs from
delivering foods and goods to health
care and so much more right now it is
imperative that good employees and good
employers be connected this is what
SuperCrew does each and every day it's
why all of my employees are always on
tenterhooks to find out whether they
have been zip recruited and replaced
today by bringing people together we
need jobs and companies that need people
zip recruiter is committed to helping
the workforce stay strong
they're gonna be very instrumental in
helping us get out of the Great
Depression sized cavity we've created
for ourselves let's work together
visit zip recruiter comm slash work
together to learn more again that zip
recruiter comm slash work together okay
so today is June 19th as I mentioned
that is Juneteenth I'm gonna read to you
from the national registry for
Juneteenth there is a there's a website
that's specifically dedicated to
Juneteenth they have a good sort of
summary of what exactly happened
Juneteenth Juneteenth is the oldest
nationally celebrated commemoration of
the ending of slavery in the United
States dating back to 1865 was on June
19th that the Union soldiers led by
Major General Gordon Granger landed at
Galveston Texas with news that the war
had ended and that the enslaved were now
free this was two and a half years after
of course the Emancipation Proclamation
which had become official on January 1st
1863 but the Emancipation Proclamation
didn't have much effect in Texas because
of course the Civil War was still on one
of General Grainger's first orders of
business when he arrived was to read to
the people of Texas General Order number
three which began most significantly
with this the people of Texas are
informed that in accordance with the
proclamation from the executive of the
United States all slaves are free this
involves an absolute equality of rights
and rights of property between former
masters and slaves and the connection
heretofore existing between them becomes
that between employer and hired laborer
as the website points out the reactions
to this profound news rain from pure
shock to immediate jubilation now of
course
Juneteenth didn't end the story of
racism in America or discrimination in
America but it was the end of slavery
and it was the the marker that America
was attempting to fill
fulfill its founding promises at
Juneteenth Tribune national holiday the
reason it should be a national holiday
is because America there's a good case
to made that America essentially had to
foundings neither one was in 1619 the
first founding was in 1776 with the
establishment of universal principles
and the second was in 1865 with the
fulfillment of the promise for black
Americans that they were not to be
slaves or to be excluded from a
constitution of the United States and
the Declaration of Independence of
course we took another century for black
Americans to really feel the full fruits
of their rights because of endemic
racism and white supremacy that existed
in the United States particularly in the
southern half of the United States but
this was the beginning of the of the
fulfillment of the dream of the of the
founding fathers that they themselves
were unable or unwilling depending on
which founder you're talking about to
fulfill so Juneteenth should absolutely
be a national holiday and in fact
they're Republicans today who are
sponsoring that I mean among other
symbols that we should be looking at by
the way Frederick Douglass good case you
should be on the on the national
currency and they've been talking about
Harriet Tubman that's fine
Harriet Tubman was a hero heroine but
Frederick Douglass is my pick Frederick
Douglass the guy who who essentially
connected the promises of the
Declaration of Independence
with the hope of black Americans living
in slavery okay so with all of that said
there should be a time to celebrate how
far American history has come because
let's be quite real about this anybody
who's attempting to link the the lives
today of black Americans with the lives
of slaves and make a comparison between
the two that that comparison just does
not exist if you were living in slavery
versus black Americans at the highest
levels of government of culture of
business having all the same rights and
in some cases having actual legally
established preferences and particularly
college admissions the idea of that
being a reality in the United States in
1865 would have been ultimately what
would have been for most for virtually
all black Americans completely
unthinkable and it is an amazing
achievement of the United States that
we've worked so hard to vitiate the evil
legacy of slavery and Jim Crow bigotry
and racism in American society however
of course we are going to discuss in the
United States this notion that all
inequality is inequity by celebrating
Juneteenth what we should be celebrating
is the movement from slavery to freedom
right the movement from the notion that
society is going to create a glass
ceiling over you to the idea that you
are essentially responsible for your own
fate and your a bit you are able to make
your own decisions and of course that
wasn't true for a hundred years after
the Civil War black Americans were
striving and fighting for their rights
they're striving and fighting to make
themselves more prosperous and to grab a
hold of the promises made in the
Declaration of Independence this is
white so irritating to me when I see
people rip on the American flag or the
Declaration of Independence all of the
great civil rights leaders from
Frederick Douglass to Booker T
Washington to Martin Luther King
recognized that the Declaration of
Independence was a promissory note that
had not been actually provided for black
Americans it had not been fulfilled for
black Americans and the promises of the
Declaration of Independence were
universal so when people talk about the
evils of the failing what they fail to
recognize is that the great civil rights
leader the best civil rights leader is
the most effective civil rights leaders
recognize that they were calling on
Americans to live up to the standards
that they had not lived up to heretofore
and it's really important to remember
that and that the goal was that when all
was said and done black and white would
be equal not in terms of result by race
but in terms of the rights that they
could grab hold to all would be treated
as individuals capable of making free
and independent decisions because that's
what freedom is the ability to make
free and independent decisions and what
that suggests is that the cause of
America when it comes to racism is
vitiating actual racism getting rid of
actual racism and it is not a substitute
to simply suggest that equality is the
is the definition equality of outcome is
the definition of anti racism because
those two things are not actually
related there's no quality of outcome in
the white community there's great income
gaps in the white community there's
great income gaps between all the people
and young people equality of outcome is
not the measure of anti racism anti
racism is the measure of anti racism
being against racism now as we're gonna
discuss the definition of racism seems
to have shifted in modern America from
you're against bigotry and
discrimination on the basis of race too
you oppose all the institutions of
American society that are shot through
with history and and with historic
racism and that shift is a really
dangerous one because it implies that
the only way to be anti-racist so to
speak is to recognize your own sin even
if you haven't sinned and to tear down
the institutions of American society
which after all were founded in white
supremacy that shift from Martin Luther
King style anti racism to
intersectionality style anti racism is
dramatic one and it leads to the sort of
stories that we are seeing today from
the New York Times the New York Times as
a piece today by Patrick Sharkey kianga
llamada Taylor and yar yar you know I'm
gonna screw up the name yari in a second
it's called the gaps between white and
black America in charge and we're gonna
go through this in a second because the
obvious implication is that the reason
that these gaps exist and have continued
to exist is because of continuing
systemic racism in the United States now
there are after-effects to history I've
said this before a thousand times on the
show they're obviously after-effects to
history if you borrow somebody from
buying a house in 1960 that will have
some follow-on effect for not being able
to give your house to your kids for
example that is true but there are
certain gaps that certainly cannot be
explained by history and that includes
the continuing wide income gap or the
education gap or the single motherhood
gap that cannot be explained by history
particularly when you are looking at
such a radical escalation in particular
communities to suggest that America is
more racist now than it was in 1960 and
when in 1960 the black single motherhood
raped by the way single motherhood is
the single greatest indicator of
intergenerational poverty when the black
single motherhood rate in 1960 was 20%
and when today it is in excess
90% and in some heavily black
communities it's a nexus of 90% that
cannot be blamed on racism it cannot
there's just no way to do it especially
because the single motherhood rate has
risen concomitant ly in the white
community just not quite as fast and you
can't cite racism when you are saying
okay I'm going to get a girl pregnant
and walk out which leads to poverty
which leads to poverty for your kid and
for your and for the woman you knocked
up if you decide to drop out of school
this is a personal decision that you
cannot blame on racism or slavery but
the attempt to say that everything that
is unequal in outcome is a is a remnant
of slavery and Jim Crow is is a
dangerous but pervasive idea in today's
modern America we're gonna get to that
in just one second first with everything
going on right now in the world some
people think it might be a bad time to
buy life insurance so now is a great
time to buy life insurance yes you
actually can buy life insurance during a
pandemic and if you have loved ones
depending on your income you probably
should as an insurance marketplace
policy genius is in contact with the
life insurance companies on their
platform every single day they're
keeping track of all the changes in the
market so you don't have to which means
they can get you covered quickly and for
the best price here's how it works
policy genius compares quotes from the
top life insurance companies in one
place it takes just a few minutes to
compare quotes from the top insurers and
find your best price this doesn't just
save a lot of legwork it could save
fifteen hundred bucks or more a year by
using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape for free so
if you had any speed bumps during the
application process they will be there
to take care of everything for you if
you're one of the many people looking to
buy life insurance right now I know a
lot of people are thinking about this
stuff looking to be responsible for
their family go check out policy genius
right now they don't just do life
insurance they do auto insurance and
disability insurance and all the
insurance it could possibly need and I
hope you find the best prices they'll
bundle it for you go check out policy
genius com they'll help you find the
best rate handle the process completely
soup-to-nuts they'll get you and your
family protected and hopefully give you
one less thing to worry about okay so
the implication of today's new take on
racism as we'll discuss there's a
fantastic fantastic author named Shelby
Steele who has talked about the
redefinition of racism he suggests that
we have changed the definition of racism
from actual racial discrimination so
when he calls globalized racism the idea
that all institutions of American life
are shot through with racism this is the
way that the media
cover all gaps write all inequality of
outcome is obvious evidence of
inequality of rights which is obviously
not true that is obviously untrue kids
within the same family have dramatically
different income dramatically different
income I have three younger sisters our
incomes are dramatically different
across the spectrum they grew up in
exactly the same house okay but the idea
from the New York Times and from so many
on the left is that if there's
inequality of outcome this evidence is
that America is continuing America's
continuing legacy of racism so as I
mentioned there's this article in The
New York Times that highlights some of
the gaps between white and black America
in charts so they show the unemployment
rate age 16 years or over and they show
that basically the the gap in the
unemployment rate between black and
white has been fairly consistent since
it actually spiked a bit the gap seems
have spiked a bit during the 1980s but
it is gone back down now to probably its
lowest point if you look at this chart
looks like the lowest point in American
history that gap bout was about 3% up
until the pandemic hit okay which is a
testament frankly to president Trump's
economy I mean that that obviously is is
the thing but the unemployment rate so
the suggestion here is that if blacks
are historically less employed than
whites even after the Civil Rights Act
and that the gap wasn't closed then
nothing must have changed or
alternatively a lot of things change
alternatively there were great society
programs that that paid welfare
alternatively there were formative
action programs designed to get people
into college of minority races
alternatively there's a change in
behavior as well to simply look at the
gap in the unemployment rate and say
racism like if all you knew was one
factor right unemployment and racism
what you would suggest as racism hasn't
changed so this chart doesn't look like
it changed all that much in terms of the
gap but obviously many things changed
including the number of black Americans
who are graduating from high school the
answer is 92 percent including the
number of black Americans who are going
to college the answer is approximately
what 26 percent now go through a
four-year college so that I mean that is
a massive difference it's a massive
difference by the way again there's this
chart it shows share of people 25 years
and over who completed four years of
college or more and it shows that the
gap between white and black has actually
risen a little bit since 1960 not that
many people went to college in 1960
period between white and black but now
today 36 percent of why
Americans over 25 completed four years
of college 26 percent of black Americans
have completed 4 years of college or
more which is an amazing amazing
statistic right over 1/4 of black
Americans are completing floors of
college or more now what you would have
to recognize also is that the black
dropout rates is a lot higher in college
than the white dropout rate in college
black student college graduation rates
remain significantly well the nationwide
college graduation rate for black
students stands at 42 percent there are
a lot of black students who are going
into college and then are not graduating
college and by the way it's it's largely
statistically speaking black men are
more likely to drop out of college than
black women are but that does explain
part of the gap so one of the things
that has happened is again people refuse
to look at ancillary factors that might
explain continuing gaps because the idea
is just a very simplistic single factor
analysis if there's a gap that gap is
due to continuing endemic racism if you
look at median household income you see
that there has been a continuing gap
between white and black and that the gap
has actually risen in terms of median
household income now you might think to
yourself okay why has the median
household income gap risen given the
fact that racism racial discrimination
and employment has been outlawed since
the 1960s in both the private and public
sectors I mean in every state in the
Union is where the Civil Rights Act in
1011 and Civil Rights Act essentially
what why exactly is that gap still
existent well you and maybe it has
something to do with high school dropout
rates maybe it has something to do with
the fact that so many public schools are
failing black students and so many black
students are graduating from high school
without actually having rudimentary
skills and have to go into remedial
education even if they go to college I
mean there are significant gaps in the
number of students by race or going into
remedial education once they had college
maybe this has to do with the fact that
there are so many single moms right that
changes the median household income if
the mom and dad are living together the
median household income rates a mom and
dad their combined income is going to be
higher if more people are unmarried
that's two separate households now right
so the household income is lower in
other words what's in your attempts is
trying to do with all of this is imply
that racism is still the deciding factor
in American life and in fact they make
this absolutely clear in the New York
Times piece they suggest that in many
parts of the country black and white
Americans continue to live in very
different worlds this distinctive
feature of American
is not an accidental development but
rather a result of policy choices again
the idea is that historic discrimination
is what has caused all of this which
would not really explain why the black
middle class was growing faster in the
1950s before the Civil Rights Act and in
today after the Civil Rights Act in 1965
another example the homeownership rate
so the homeownership rate prior to 1990
right going all the way back to about
1980 there's a huge gap between white
homeownership and black homeownership
well as black income has risen and it
has risen dramatically from 1960 and on
wouldn't you expect more black
homeownership and yet black
homeownership is actually at the lowest
levels that it has been since 1990 so
what exactly is going on here you can't
really blame redlining for lack of
homeownership by black Americans in 2020
at this point well you can blame is
rising real estate prices and low income
right that's what you can blame how
about sentenced male prisoners per
100,000 residents of the corresponding
group so the idea here is that black
Americans are being discriminated
against in the criminal justice system
okay so the gap has actually dropped
fairly dramatically from what it once
was over the past 20 years but for every
100,000 black males 2272 of them will
end up sentenced to prison as opposed to
392 for every 100,000 white males is
that the result of racism or is that the
result of individuals making criminal
decisions right that the the basic
notion here that the New York Times is
pushing and this is the notion that the
left is pushing is that all inequality
of outcome is due to discrimination
continuing discrimination in the system
which is not correct it is not factually
correct when we look at the actual
rationales for why income has remained
low or why for example there young black
men who are growing up in high-income
households are significantly more likely
to fall out of the top quintile than
young black women you have to determine
whether there are individual decisions
that are at play here or you have to
remove the confounds but for the left
it's not necessary to remove the
confounds because the only thing that is
important is implying that all of
America's institutions are systemically
racist and therefore the onus is on
restructuring those institutions so as
to achieve equal outcome not equal
rights and this view has infused so much
of our of our public thinking right now
and what it does really is it
white liberals responsible for it's
incredibly paternalistic it makes white
liberal is responsible for the uplift of
black Americans right that's that's
really what it is it's a bunch of white
liberals feeling good about themselves
because how man these systems are so bad
but you know what
I can fight racism because I these poor
black people you know I'm I can't hold
them to the decision not to have a child
out of wedlock or to finish high school
but if I restructure the system I can
feel so good about myself and I can it's
really on me it's really on me me the
white liberal to fix life for the
individual black person even if the
equal rights are guaranteed by the
Constitution by law in every state in
the United States it's up to me to to
guarantee equal outcome it makes people
feel so good and not only does it make
people feel good it leads to what
Condoleezza Rice has correctly called
the soft bigotry of low expectations and
this is how you end up with articles
like this one from dr. Robin DG Kelly
professor of American history in The New
York Times called what kind of society
values property over over black lives
the idea being should professor of
American history at UCLA the the basic
idea being that we cannot expect as
Americans black Americans not to riot
and loot and burn things right the idea
being because all of the systems are so
inherently corrupt that it causes black
anger and therefore it is wrong to
expect black Americans not to riot and
burn and loot things what why first of
all I think it's I think everyone should
not write and burn and loot it turns out
there are some white Americans doing
that too but you don't get to riot and
loot and burn things because the the
supposition here is that all inequality
again of outcome is the result of evils
in the American system and that rage and
that people cannot therefore be expected
to operate within the system that
operating within the system is itself a
form of bowing to the system and the
system itself is inherently racist and
therefore the truest form of fighting
against the system is things like
rioting and looting this is the soft
bigotry of low expectations Condoleezza
Rice was talking about we can't expect
people to abide by the law because after
all the law was originally founded in
racism in 1619 and therefore expecting
people to abide by the law and live
under the quote/unquote racist regime
that means that you are asking people to
sacrifice their own honor to obey the
law and that is not what it's it's
absurd on its face it is it does not
make the lives of black Americans better
in any way
conceivably like any way at all because
it turns out the path to prosperity in
the United States is wide open if you
make the right decisions only 2% of
Americans who do the following three
things graduate high school don't have a
kid before you are married and get a job
end up in permanent poverty in the
United States according the Brookings
Institute you do those three things you
won't end up in permanent poverty the
soft bigotry of low expectations is one
of the more dangerous things that is
happening in the United States right now
and it's tearing the country apart and
it's largely being pressed by white
liberals who want to feel good about
themselves and establish their moral
superiority to their fellow white person
for acknowledging their own sin and
subtly to establish their own white
supremacy by suggesting the black people
are incapable of taking care of
themselves and need white saviors to
come in and help them that's it which
which Shelby Steele writes about this
and he is exactly right we're gonna get
into Shelby Steele's perspective he
expresses it better than I can express
it for sure when you get to that in just
a moment first you know as strongly I
believe in individual liberty and
personal responsibility our founding
fathers knew these were the cornerstones
from great civilization that's why they
created the Second Amendment to secure
every American's fundamental human right
to protect themselves their family and
their community that said owning a rifle
is an awesome responsibility building
rifles is no different that's why I'm so
impressed with Bravo company
manufacturing like owning a gun right
now makes an awful lot of sense we have
an entire wing of American political
life suggesting you shouldn't own a gun
only the police should have guns and
also the police shouldn't exist so guys
you might want to have a gun the people
at Bravo Company MFG support the right
of responsible private individuals to
have the access and ability to employ
the same tools as civilian law
enforcement as a means of defending
ourselves our loved ones our communities
and our freedoms should a threatening
situation ever arise BCM assumes that
when a rifle leaves their shop it will
be used in a life-or-death situation by
a responsible citizen law enforcement
officer or a soldier overseas so quality
is of the utmost value to them every
components of the BCM rifle is hand
tested and assembled as an American you
have a luxury of living in a free
society where you can improve your life
through education and religious
exploration and the open exchange of
ideas
you know guarantees all those rights the
Second Amendment to learn more about
bravo company manufacturing head on over
to Bravo Company MFG comm you can
discover more about their products
special offers upcoming news that's
Bravo Company MFG comm if you need more
convincing find out even more about BCM
and the awesome people who make their
products at youtube.com slash Bravo
Company USA so as I say the idea that
all inequality of outcome is due to
array
system leads to the soft bigotry of low
expectations in which we can't expect
black Americans not to loot kid is an
actual article in the New York Times by
a professor of American history dr.
Robin Kelly at the New York Times why
are they looting it's asked every time
protests against police violence erupted
into civil unrest we know the answer is
by now
poverty anger age rage in a sense of
helplessness for some it is a form of
political violence for others
destructive opportunism there appears to
be no single motive that white youth
figure prominently among looters during
the recent wave of unrest confounds easy
explanations no it actually doesn't it
actually doesn't it turns out the vast
majority of people who are looting have
no interest in making a political
statement they are instead just stealing
crap and it's true for white people it
is true for black people if you are
getting a TV off the back of George
Floyd you're not doing anything for
George Floyd you're just a piece of crap
but we can't say that right we're not
supposed to say that because apparently
looting is a form of standing up to the
system this is the same mentality that
led Maxine Waters to call the LA riots
which largely burned down black
neighborhoods in Los Angeles the LA
uprising uprising against what against
the system itself right according to
this columnist let me offer a more
productive question instead what is the
effect of obsessing over looting it's a
flex from the core problem that brought
people to the streets the people the
police keep killing us with impunity
instead ones burning and looting start
the media often shifts to the futility
of violence as legitimate paths to
justice
crime becomes the story riots we are
told caused harm by foreclosing
constructive solutions but such
rebellions have not only shined a
spotlight on American racism they have
also spawned investigations and limited
reforms when traditional appeals have
failed the evidence for this is
extraordinarily limited but again this
is all in in pursuit of the myth that
the greatest obstacle to black success
in the United States is white racism and
now the the kind of bleeding edge of
that is supposedly the police and this
is how you end up with the New York
Times talking about the Rashard Brooks
shooting in Atlanta this way police
decisions are scrutinized after ray
shard Brooks's fatal encounter the
original headline was Rashard Brooks his
final hour was a jarring panorama of
policing Rashard Brooks resisted arrest
after a 25 minute conversation with
police officers wrestled two police
officers to the ground took a Taser off
a police officer tried to tase one
police officer and then while running
away tried to tase another police
officer and was shot for his trouble
that is not a panorama of policing
that's a man acting like a criminal who
was shot
defiantly and that's what a jerk that's
what a grand jury is gonna find the
charges in this Atlanta case are absurd
but again if the police are stand-ins
for the evil system then the police are
the ones who have to answer for a man
acting like a criminal we can't of
course expect Rashard Brooks not to act
like a criminal because to do so would
be to engage in the fallacy that people
are responsible for their own actions in
the end in a free country now none of
this has any relationship to reality
right in terms of the general idea that
police are the the greatest obstacle to
black freedom in America it's just not
correct in fact and the officer in this
particular case in Atlanta he gave CPR
to Rashad Brooks after he shot and gave
CPR to him hey but the narrative holds
and and it combines with a narrative of
white penitence right white penitence
and the white penitence is not designed
to actually alleviate the problem the
white penance assistance the white
penitence is designed instead to do
something else and that is to
reestablish the moral authority of white
liberals and because the the argument is
that white people lost moral authority
because of Jim Crow and racism and
slavery which is completely fair on
issues of race and the only way that the
moralist or authority can be restored is
if white people who are liberal express
their guilt and then proceed to treat
black people paternalistically by
offering a bunch of of systemic changes
right being against the system becomes
the marker of being a good person and
that's what white liberals are doing
right now I'm gonna get some more of
this in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that right now saving
every penny you can is particularly
important including on your credit card
balance get a credit card consolidation
loan from light stream right now you
could save thousands in interest like
now is a great time to not spend 20% APR
on a loan that you got from the credit
card company get a rate as low as five
point nine five percent APR with Auto
pay and excellent credit they've got
lower than average credit card interest
rates of over 19 per the lower than
average credit card interest rate is 19%
APR 5 2015 10 credit with light stream
which is gonna save you an awful lot of
money apply to day you get a special
interest rate discount and save even
more the only way to get the discount is
to go to light stream comm slash up here
you don't want to rack up all those
charges on your credit card and then
this is how people step spirals out of
control
I know people this has happened to I've
referred them to light stream Li ght
Str I am calm slash appear that's light
stream calm slash Shapiro apply today
get a special interest rate discount and
save even more again the only way to get
that discount go to light stream comm
slash appear o subject at credit
approval rate includes 0.50% auto pay
discount terms and conditions apply
offers are subject to change without
notice visit light stream comm slash
appear o for more information hey so I
wanna read you from a fantastic book by
the author Shelby Steele who teaches
over at Hoover Institute and the book is
called white guilt and it really does
explain I think in detail the worldview
that ends with the belief that all
quality inequality of outcome is in evil
in America and explains why we are
seeing these religious these acts of
religious penitence from the from the
left from the white left particularly
and why we are seeing the attempts to
rip away American history I mean there's
a George Washington statute that got
torn down in Portland yesterday is all
the peace so I never do this but I think
that this is a very important subject
and I'm gonna let somebody who is more
well-versed on this than I speak to you
here so Shelby Steele again in his book
white guilt he talked about white guilt
he says white guilt is quote the vacuum
of moral authority that comes from
simply knowing that one's race is
associated with racism whites and
American institutions must acknowledge
historical racism to show themselves
redeemed of it but once they acknowledge
it they lose moral authority over
everything having to do with race
equality social justice poverty and so
on they step into a void of
vulnerability the authority they lose
transfers to the victims of historical
racism and becomes their great power in
society so in other words when you
acknowledge the guilt the white guilt
that that white supremacy was a
governing force in the United States you
immediately lose all authority to speak
on moral questions okay because white
guilt is a vacuum of moral authority
says Shelby Steele it makes the moral
authority of whites and the legitimacy
of American institutions contingent on
proving a negative that they are not
racist whites and American institutions
are stigmatized as racist until they
prove otherwise white guilt leaves no
room for moral choice it does not depend
on the goodwill or the genuine decency
of people it depends on their fear of
stigmatization
their fear of being called a racist
right because if you are called the
racist you lose moral authority and you
are links to a past that you don't
belong to but because you are a member
of the white race you are therefore
guilty by association with the people
who were
creators of these institutions and did
exist in regime of white supremacy you
combine this with the new redefinition
of racism so it used to be that you were
guilty for your own racist act right if
your own racist feelings that was the
Martin Luther King version of racism he
was trying to wipe from the human heart
and largely was successful in doing so
then there is the broader version of
racism hid a broader version of racism
is an essentially marxist version of
racism says Shelby Steele ugly human
prejudices like racism did not just
remain isolated in the hearts of racists
these dark passions worked by an
invisible hand to generate societal
structures that impersonally oppress as
people simply conform to mundane
standards of social decency they
executed a bigotry and shaped society
around it without feeling animus toward
minorities the Marxian emphasis on
structures and substructures gave the
new militant leaders of the time is the
60s an infinitely larger racism to work
with a systemic and sociological racism
that was far more determinative than the
simpler immoral racism of Martin Luther
King era so the Martin Luther King
racism says their America would be free
except for these obstacles institutional
obstacles of racism get rid of the
institutional obstacles of racism Jim
Crow laws racism in interactions and we
will now be free and now the freedom is
on us right responsibilities on us once
you suggest that it has infused all of
the institutions and the institutions
themselves define human beings the only
way to change the system is to rip down
the institutions that is a very Marxist
view of human life that the institutions
shaped you that people did not shape the
institutions and that your fundamental
decency within the context of an evil
system does not change the evil system
right you can say as much as you want
I'm not a racist so long as you are part
of an institutionally racist system
there is no getting away from the fact
that simply by upholding the system you
are adherent to racism Shelby Steele
says globalized racism this is the new
definition of racism is quote racism
inflated into a deterministic structural
and systemic power global racism seeks
to make every racist event the tip of
the iceberg so the redress will be to
the measure of the iceberg rather than
to the measure of its tip right because
once you say that everything is infused
with racism all you have to do is point
to a hot spot like George Floyd or I'm
at our Barry and then say that this is
the entire United States writ small
right that's the tip of the iceberg now
we have to attack the structures it is a
Rican septal ization of racism designed
to capture the fruit of the new and vast
need in white America for moral
authority and racial matters and this is
really the key right the basic idea here
is that if
people are suffering from racial guilt
because as they should they look to the
history of the United States and are
ashamed by white supremacy that if that
is the case the way that white people
particularly white liberals seek to
re-establish moral authority is to prove
that they are not racist and the way to
prove that they are not racist is by
standing aside from the institutions
that supposedly are shot through with
racism
so dissociation becomes the key
dissociation and labeling and cancel
culture these become a key by the way
Shelby still is writing this in 2006 he
says suddenly in American life the
matter of responsibility was qualified
by a new social morality if you are a
black and thus a victim of racial
oppression there's a new morality of
social justice meant you could not be
expected to carry the same
responsibilities as others right in
other words because of social justice
and the history of racial oppression we
can't expect you not to loot right
that's the piece in the New York Times
the point was that American society no
longer had the moral authority to
enforce a single standard of
responsibility for everyone because by
its own admission it had not treated
everyone the same thus in the national
consciousness after the 60s individual
responsibilities became synonymous with
injustice when applied to blacks thus
since the 60s black leaders have made
one overriding argument that blacks
cannot achieve equality without white
America taking responsibility for it and
this just suits white liberals twitty
the idea that equality can only be
established if they are given the power
to restructure American society because
it invests them again with moral
authority the moral authority they've
lost because of white guilt so now they
have the power to restructure American
society and not it's great not only do
they get to show that they're better
than other white people for having
accepted white guilt they also then get
to restructure institutions without
actually caring what happens to black
people who are harmed by the
restructuring of those institutions this
is why you see so many white upper crust
liberals in Hollywood tweeting about
defund the police when they won't be
affected by defund the police one iota
this leads Shelby Steele sense to white
blindness a blindness to the human
reality of minorities that occurs when
whites look at racial issues but see
only the contingency they must meet to
restore their own moral authority
another what in other words what do I
have to do to make myself feel better
and make me feel like I'm on top of the
moral pantheon again white blindness is
an unconscious self absorption by which
whites see racial issues and even
interracial encounters as opportunities
to dissociate from historic racism every
time you interact with a black person is
an opportunity for you to show that you
are not a racist and therefore recap
for moral authority and of course you
can't recapture moral authority unless
you rip the entire system which as we
have said is an indicator of globalized
racism dissociation requires evidence of
a proactive effort a self-conscious and
highly visible display this all Shelby
Steele and again I'm reading two at
length here because I think that he
expresses this almost so much more
eloquently than I would he says people
who are in the grip of white blindness
and thus unaware of their true
motivations always miss the human being
inside the black skin your color
represents you in the mind of such
people they will have built a large part
of their moral identity and possibly
their politics about around how they
respond to your color that's a part of
them the moral part is invested not in
you but in some idea of what your color
means and when they see you the
individual you a black person they
instantly call to mind this investment
and determine once again to honor it
they're very likely proud of the way
they've learned to relate to your color
proud of the moral magnanimity it gives
them an opportunity to express so in
meeting you they actually meet only a
well-rehearsed and better part of
themselves is the sort of pretension
that Jordan Peele mocks and get out the
people who are walking around with Kente
cloths and saying they voted for Obama
twice so she'll be still in the age of
white guilt white blindness has been
driven not by racism but by the white
need to dissociate from racism whites
are blind to blacks as human beings
today not out of bigotry but out of
their obsession with achieving the
dissociation they need to restore their
moral authority when they find a way to
dissociate from racism diversity
politically correct language political
liberalism itself there's a little under
incentive to understand blacks as human
beings dissociation that makes whites
human again it gives white the right to
speak on these issues the more you say
that America is racist the more you say
your fellow citizens are racist the more
you say the systems are racist the moral
authority you have this is why you will
see people kneeling they're not kneeling
to express actual penitence they're
kneeling to reestablish moral authority
post 60s American liberalism says Shelby
Steele preserves the old racist
hierarchy of whites over blacks as
virtue itself and it grants all whites
who identify with a new superiority in
effect it says you are morally superior
to other whites and intellectually
superior to blacks the white liberals
reward is this feeling that because he
has erred to the knowledge of the West
yet morally enlightened beyond the
former the West's former bigotry he is
really a new man a better man than the
world has seen before because this
association is a claim of superiority it
generates a kind of collective
narcissism an irrational yet utterly
certain belief in the moral superiority
of post six East associate dissociation
of liberalism dissociation of meaning
you just hose
from all the institution's you say I'm
not associated with it I dissociate from
those institutions and from a history of
American racism in this liberalism one
does not argue by logical principle one
argues by dissociation only ends
association our authority legitimacy and
power available when the American Left
responded to the crisis of white guilt
and began to define social virtue as
mere dissociation it effectively started
the culture war dissociation is always
achieved at the expense of democratic
principles and demanding values grounded
in fairness and individual
responsibility what in shorthand might
be called the culture of principle is
important stuff because as we're going
to see all of the sort of virtues
signaling that you are seeing from the
weather from from the white left today
is about dissociation it is about an
attempt to re-establish moral authority
and it is about control it is not about
healing the country it is not about
making the country a better place
because if you actually want black
Americans to be just as successful as
white Americans and close all of those
gaps what you actually want is for
people to make successful decisions on
an individual level that lead to success
that is the thing you want more than
anything in the world
what you want is not to incentivize
behavior that leads to unsuccess or
pretend that a few affirmative action
stops are going to solve the problem of
bad education in the black community
overall by statistics what you don't
want is these sort of displays of pathos
what you actually want are more
opportunities more freedoms and more
demands for individual responsibility
Barack Obama tried this and Barack Obama
was shouted out of the room by a lot of
people on the left when he suggested
that individual responsibility was the
first key to black Americans rising in a
free society that of course is 100% true
and it's true for everyone not just
black Americans is true for white
Americans it's for Hispanic Americans
it's true for Asian Americans if you
want Americans to do well you need to
recommend that freedom be exercised
responsibly and that you white liberals
you are not responsible for your own
savior complex paternalistic I'm going
to restructure the systems so certain
people are redressed of history's
grievances again that's particularly
from when you're talking about people
who are two generations removed at this
point from the Civil Rights Act and at
least five generations removed from
slavery now you have to be talking
instead about what are the actual
factors behind these gaps not what makes
you feel good by creating some program
that is likely to be unsuccessful this
is why you see people shouting about the
police at the same time that what many
members of the black community I would
say the vast majority of black Americans
who are living in high crime areas need
more than anything else is more policing
more policing they need a less crime in
their neighborhoods that's what leads to
investment that's what leads to people
bringing their money in and their tax
dollars that then go to the local
schools but instead it's all about white
people I mean so much of this really is
about white guilt and white blindness
that's the real problem here it really
is a huge problem we're gonna get to the
displays of penitence that really are
dishonest in one second first let us
talk about something great that you can
do for Father's Day so imagine your
father opening up something he got in
the mailings like what is this for
Father's Day what could it possibly be
and it is steak
you just want Father's Day my friend
Omaha Steaks they have a limited time
Father's Day offer for our listeners go
to Omaha Steaks com enter the code
Shapiro into the search bar and say 55%
on the gift dad will love for $79.99
your gift will include for naturally
lean top sirloin steaks hand-carved and
aged at least 21 days for tenderness and
flavor for premium boneless chicken
breasts for gourmet jumbo Franks and
kielbasa sausages a package of savory
all beef meatballs for perfectly browned
potatoes au gratin for made from scratch
caramel apple tartlets and an Omaha
Steaks signature seasoning packet I mean
this is great stuff they actually sent
me some kosher steaks to try let me just
tell you that aging process whoof
that is some good stuff right there dad
we'll get all of this delicious food
plus the free pound of steak bacon it's
amazing gift is ready to be shipped
straight to dad in time for Father's Day
$79.99 this Father's Day sends out the
gift he really wants go to Omaha Steaks
com type Shapiro in the search bar say
55% when you send that summer sizzle
pack for $79.99 get free steak cut bacon
with your order don't wait head on over
to Omaha Steaks comtex shapiro in the
search bar and order these summer sizzle
pack for Father's Day today ok well
we're gonna get into the Acts of
penitence the displays of penitence that
really are about the re-establishment of
moral authority by white leftists who
want to feel superior to other white
people and also want to feel
paternalistic toward black people and
not treat black Americans as individual
human beings just as capable and many
cases more capable than white Americans
of making good decisions when you get to
that in just one second first you know
it's that time of the week when we when
we show somebody with the tumblr right
is the tumblr time of week the magical
is about to happen
so here's today's it comes
courtesy of Emily Kobayashi she shows
herself holding a leftist tears tumbler
standing above Chaz you can actually see
Chaz over the background she's
delightfully labelled it for she's a
tenth floor view of our nascent nation
state where the leftist tears are
flowing as the proletariat suffer soy
loaf shortages hashtag leftist ears
tumblers well done Emily well done in
the picture again she's a surgeon so
she's doing some good for the world
unlike the people over in Chaz thanks
for the picture keep up the work keep up
the good work stay safe out there in all
of the insanity if you're not already a
daily wire member you should consider
getting a reader's pass to daily wire
comm it's a great value for only 3 bucks
a month when you sign up you get that
first month for only 99 cents you also
get access to a mobile app articles ad
free and access to exclusive editorials
like this one Matt Walsh has a brand new
article called no America didn't invent
slavery which of course is a hundred
percent true slavery has been endemic to
humankind since history like all of it
ok and the idea that America is uniquely
evil because America had slavery in it
is not true America American slavery was
in evil but in a very deep evil and
America deserves all the guilt for its
slavery but to pretend that it was an
outlier in human history is simply
absurd if you haven't checked out the
readers pass already go to daily wear
comm and sign up before just one buck go
check them out right now
daily Wired icon you get the readers
pass or just get the general all-access
pass which comes with access to all
access live which is a blast I hang out
with you wear t-shirts and all of the
rest head on over to daily wear dot-com
become part of the team this is the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so we are now in this in the spin cycle
of what can you do to prove that you're
not racist what can you do to prove
you're not racist well you can
disassociate from anything that could
tangentially be perceived as racist you
can disassociate from all of America's
institutions you Kansas OC eight from
America's history as Shelby Steele says
the key to white blindness and white
guilt and banishing white guilt via
white blindness is to dissociate from
exactly the institutions that are most
likely to grant success to everyone if
proper decisions are made and they're
there plenty of grifters in this space
Robyn D'Angelo is the author of a book
called white fragility and what I love
about this is the Robbins Angela's white
off for making just a bundle off of I
mean her book was like number one on
amazon.com all about white fragility and
the book is just a trashy it basically
suggests that even if you're concerned
about racism this is just evidence of
white fragility basically no matter what
you do if you're white you're wrong
which is a great way for you also to
establish your moral authority you just
say I'm wrong all the time that's not
actually a way for you to say sorry it's
a way for you to say I'm better than all
these other white people and also I am
responsible for all the world's ills by
the way when you acknowledge you are
responsible for all the world's ills
when you take the world's ills on your
shoulders
doesn't it gray you an awful lot of
authority like a tremendous amount of
authority so she appeared with Jimmy
Fallon because our late-night TV has
basically just become woke programming
at this point here's Robin DeAngelo with
a crappy book white fragility on Jimmy
Fallon last night okay so what if you
could just give us feedback on our
inevitable and often unaware racist
assumptions and behaviors and I'll never
forget this black man raising his hand
and saying it would be revolutionary and
you know this like just take that in I
just want all the white people that just
take that in revolutionary that we would
receive the feedback with grace reflect
and seek to change our behavior that's
how difficult we are
Wow that's how big a holes who we are
Jimmy Fallon just like he wants to die
and I mean honestly like if I were
interviewing this person I probably
would want to die as well because again
the entire premise of the book is that
white people are the most important
people in the entire universe
right this is the it's the essence of
white leftist arrogance white people are
the most important people in the world
their feelings about race are the
defining features of the world today
all credit and all blame goes on their
shoulder and as long as you dissociate
associate associate right that's why
you're getting canceled culture right
now because the the threat of being
called a racist is so high right now
that you have to just dissociate from
everything how high is the threat that
you're getting these this abject virtue
signaling from the stupidest places the
chick-fil-a CEO actually asked yesterday
for white people to shine black people's
shoes to show embarrassment for racism
so I have a basic biblical principle it
actually differentiates I would say
judeo-christian values from Hammurabi's
code Hammurabi's code you could actually
criminally sentence a child for the sins
of their parents right your parent
murdered somebody you execute the child
the Bible says you're not allowed to
revisit the sins of the fair of the
father's on the sons right this is one
of the key standards here so how about
this how about you repent to the person
that you sinned against but not for sins
that somebody else did how about that
but the idea here is that you are
supposed to individually shine a an
individual black person's shoes because
of a sin that you did not commit against
a black person that you don't even know
this is Dan Kathy's idea of how we are
going to cure the country really well
done and again what this is really about
is then and I don't dislike Dan Kathy I
mean the guy the guy is pro traditional
marriage by most accounts he's concerned
but this is insane okay this is purely
insane here he is saying that white
people should shine black people's shoes
to show embarrassment for racism
I invite folks is to to put some words
to action here and if we need to find
somebody that needs to have this shoe
shine we need to just go right on over
and shine their shoes and whether they
got tennis shoes are owned or not maybe
they got sandals own it really doesn't
matter but there's a time which we need
to have you know some some personal
action here maybe they've heard I have a
question what did he did he liked it the
guy shoes dirty and what what in the if
that feels awkward to you it's because
it is awkward and it's about that CEO
now he can say when somebody says you're
a racist no no didn't you see that video
of me shining a black man's shoes that's
how not racist I am that's how not
racist I am and let me tell you I am
solely responsible for the failures of
everybody else around like the height of
arrogance the height of silliness and
this is
the same kind of principles that are
pushed by by Robyn D'Angelo in white
fragility again she asserts things like
whiteness is not just a skin color it's
an entire system of oppression all white
people are complicit in perpetuating
this system is the basic idea and once
you accept that well then I guess that
it all does become Shelby Steele's
dissociation that's it that's all it's
about
how far does this stupidity go here's
how far it goes yesterday in Oakland
there were some quote-unquote nurses in
a park they weren't News's Hey Oakland's
mayor said five ropes found hanging from
trees in a city park our nooses and
racially charged symbols of terror her
name is Libby Schaaf is the same woman
who suggested that she was going to warn
all the illegal immigrants in the
Oakland area before I skimmed it down
okay these things do not look remotely
like nooses by the way not remotely like
nooses if you've ever seen a news this
does not look like a news this looks
like workout equipment because this
workout equipment and guess what it
turns out to have been workout equipment
the police department provided five
photographs of trees some of which
should not in robes and one that
appeared to have a piece of plastic pipe
attached to a rope hanging from tree
limbs oh you mean like to do I don't
know push-ups you mean to do like polls
right this is all stuff that people do
in gyms they'll remove by city officials
so who put them up Viktor sangmi who is
black told kgo-tv that the ropes were
part of a rigging that he and his
friends used as part of a larger swing
system he also shared video of the
swinging news out of the dozens and
hundreds and thousands of people that
walk by Nona's thought it looked
anywhere close to a news he says folks
have tried using it for exercise it was
a really fun addition to the park we
tried to create it's unfortunate that a
genuine gesture of just wanting to have
a good time that misinterpreted into
something so heinous Schaaf said that
they were going to do a hate crime
investigation anyway she said officials
must start with the assumption these are
hate crimes and then the mayor and
Nicholas Williams the city's director of
parks recreation said it didn't matter
whether the ropes were meant to send a
racist message
she says intentions don't matter when it
comes to terrorizing the public here is
Libby Schaaf talk about dissociation
she's not only disassociated
dissociating from racism here she's
dissociating from crap that isn't even
racist and was put up in a public park
by a black man for exercise to
demonstrate just how not racist she is
if this is if this is the height of
navel-gazing
I don't know what is here's Libby Schaaf
explaining the intentions don't matter
when it comes to a hate crime
investigation I have a question how good
intentions possibly not matter in a hate
crime investigation the entire crime is
the hate which is the intent how could
you possibly suggest intentions don't
matter in a hate crimes investigation
and by the way if that's not true then I
said if she's right she just go ahead
and prosecute the black guy for putting
up exercise equipment in the park she
just go ahead and do it
prosecute him for a hate crime say that
he was a racist for putting up exercise
equipment in a park that doesn't look
like a news but might be construed by
someone as a news here's Libby Schaaf
idiot mayor of Oakland we have to see
this moment for what it is a reckoning
and in Oakland we cannot further
terrorized or traumatize our black
residents and yes the incidents of the
last few weeks but frankly of the last
few centuries is the backdrop upon which
we have to make these decisions today
enough is enough and again the
intentions do not matter because the
harm is real no the harm is not real and
no the intentions do matter and also if
you're gonna talk about oppression over
the centuries let's see it goes
something like this black slavery Jim
Crow exercise equipment in the park put
up by a black guy in Oakland not even on
the chart Libby Schaaf via idiots his
stupid dolt
she says the symbolism of the rope
hanging in the tree is malicious
regardless of intent it's evil and it
symbolizes hatred man that feeling of
white guilt must be the feeling of white
guilt which is connected with the once
it's been alleviated the feeling of
white supremacy she's better than all
the other white people and she's more
intelligent than all the black people
who must be patriarchal he cared for by
her right doesn't matter if a black
person was offended by a thing that is
completely not offensive
well then Libby Schaaf is here to take
care of you like it's so it's so
paternalistic it's so insanely
paternalistic it's just ridiculous
and this is also what stands behind the
tearing down of the statutes right
you're just associating from American
history if you dissociate from American
history than your good and it's not
enough to dissociate from Confederate
American history right that's not enough
to dissociate from by the way I don't
think that Americans should dissociate
from American history I don't I think
they should
American history and they should study
American history and they should realize
the evils of American history
dissociating does no good dissociating
is about you relieving your own feelings
of inadequacy
it doesn't actually answer the problem
of American history it's designed to
make you feel better dissociating right
but Tarrant Allen George Washington
statues gang goes to the broader
argument America's evil America's racist
the proof that America's evil and
America's racist is inequality of
outcome that can only be alleviated by
white leftist fixing America by ripping
down her institutions to prove they're
not racist and to reestablish their
moral authority so you got a bunch of
white people in in Portland pulling down
a Washington statue again the founder of
the United States
big crowd pulling it and then burning
American flag on top of it pretty
obvious what is going on here pretty
obvious what is going on here it's it's
an absurdity it's a disgrace but that is
that is the goal the goal is tear down
the system tear down the system all to
make mostly white leftists feel better
that really is what so much of this is
about and guess what
tearing down the system isn't gonna help
black Americans is not gonna help black
Americans black Americans if they were a
country black Americans they would be I
believe what was it the 20th most
prosperous country on planet Earth if
black Americans were their own country
the pathway to success in America for
black Americans is the same as the
pathway to success for everyone else
because this is a free country and black
people are free and independent and
fully capable of making incredible
decisions which the vast majority of
them do which the vast vast majority of
black Americans do the white paternalism
of the left is despicable and the
attempt to tear down the only
institutions that have ever provided for
the prosperity the wild prosperity of
vast differences in race over time is
the system that has prevailed in the
United States thank God and we have
moved beyond the legalized racism of Jim
Crow we've moved beyond slave that's
what Juneteenth is about celebrating and
the the the price of freedom for all
Americans white black right left the
price of freedom is individual
responsibility and making good decisions
and the best thing you can do for
somebody is tell them that they have
opportunity the United States take hold
of it with both hands take hold of it
with both hands grab the opportunity
take advantage of the opportunity and if
you actually see an instance
of Martin Luther King style definition
racism you know somebody's standing in
her way then tell us about it but don't
give me we have to tear down the entire
system and don't give me that noose is
in the park that are not nooses are
actually just part of American history
and don't give me and don't give me that
looting and rioting are okay so long as
they are carried out by people who have
been historically victimized that is
soft bigotry of low expectations crap
and all it does is make white leftist
feel better and it does not forward the
the access and the success of black
Americans one iota already we will be
back here later today for two additional
hours of content otherwise have yourself
a weekend okay really take the weekend
off and enjoy as I recommend it I mean I
read from it broadly today go buy a copy
of white guilt by Shelby Steele I think
it is incredibly both evocative and
insightful go check that out as opposed
to one of these stupid books about white
fragility that is soaring up the
bestseller charts to make white leftist
feel better go go check out Shelby
Steele and read that over the weekend
that'll give you something to do we'll
see you back here on Monday I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas executive producer Jeremy
boring supervising producer
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
assistant director Pavel why douse key
technical producer Austin Stevens
playback and media operated by Nick
Sheehan associate producer Katie Swinton
edited by Adam SCI events audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mina
hair and makeup is by Anika Geneva the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh oh it's not just
another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen
you